but but what I'm saying like so a lot of
times like women sort of try to Rebrand
it just doesn't really seem like genuine
it's not really rebranding its growth
like at the end of the day if you're
going to be the same first of your life
you're never going to get anywhere it
might not be but I'm just telling you
how like men see it is okay listen
generally listen but this is this isn't
this isn't the men for me I'm telling
you this is how like men see it where
it's like before the men I gave this
away for free now you pay a premium
price and so what that says to the men
is you're not genuinely attracted to
them because you were genuinely
attracted to the first guy because you
had sex with him right away but you're
not that attracted to the second because
you're making him wait and bro I would
even I would even say that like you're
like again going back to like your
body's a temple it's not even just like
your body's Temple it's also like what
food you eat you know how you treat your
body like are you working out like are
you taking care of yourself like these
things are part of that and I think if
you're doing all of those things then
yeah that both people should wait